welcome to our bioinformatics community
now that you have successfully signed up
on the learn.omikslogic portal let's see
what the next steps are you need to
click on a login id in the menu bar on
the portal itself that will redirect you
to your profile please make sure that
you have an updated profile picture and
also your name should be in title keys
because that is the format that will be
reflected on the certificate
also connect all your social media
accounts to your profile tab because we
would often be featuring you based on
your progress on the portal and add a
brief pi about yourself so we know your
research background and interest as well
also you need to make sure that you have
the badge on your profile for whichever
program you have enrolled for and your
starter subscription should be active if
you are a part of any of the program or
have taken up the starter subscription
now let's see how we have to navigate
through various courses and project
examples on the portal so if you click
on the courses tab you will be
redirected to this page
here you can see a lot of tags added so
you have a tag for all the courses a
project tab for all the example projects
that you you can explore the example
projects give you a methodology and a
workflow that should be followed for
whichever concepts you will learn for
the courses on the portal itself
and also then you have various omics uh
fields which are genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics and data science as well
which includes r and python for
bioinformatics
so by clicking on the courses tab all
the courses will be listed out that you
can explore and learn from
so let's say you just click on any one
of the courses
be it transcriptomics
having been clicked on this particular
course you can see a lot of lessons are
there under this particular course
similarly a lot of lessons are also
there for each and every course
having a free sign up account gives you
the access only to the free lessons for
each and every course and project
example
and if you would like to get the start
material unlocked for you then you need
to visit the pricing module and pick up
the starter subscription so that all of
the start material gets unlocked
and that is the way how you can proceed
with by going and exploring all the
various courses on the portal
once you have the starter subscription
active you can then complete all the
lessons under the courses tab on the
portal and then go to your profile and
find whichever program or course you are
a part of and after completing the
course or the program you would be able
to also download your certificate from
the profile tab itself it's that simple